[Music]
we all understand the domino effect
where a single event causes a chain
reaction of similar events the most
famous example thing of course Domino's
but what if the Domino could tip over
more than its own weight and what if
each subsequent Domino got bigger and
heavier could you get to epic
proportions with that domino effect that
is our question can pushing over a
single humble Domino set up a chain
reaction of bigger and bigger dominoes
until you could crush it on our that's
what we're going to try and answer and I
have faith in this guy I have named him
[Applause]
number 12 I don't really feel like one
of those announcers so much as a kid
running out of breath screaming for his
new life next up at 2,000 81 pounds is
number 11 sound like olórin down the
number 11 is going up to make weight
he's on a pre-fight diet of concrete
well all of our heavy steel dominoes the
latter half of the sequence are in place
it only took a couple of forklifts about
12 people and twice as much time as we
were hoping to spend on it lucky number
oh now it's time for Team Domino to come
out and set up the front half of the
Ring rumored they had great results with
this in the shop but the entire sequence
has never been tested it is still just a
theoretical exercise until cannon tips
over Dominick that's when we find out if
this works with the final prep in
progress cue the unfortunate crushy
check out our new car
my name is Carlotta park a lot I'm
definitely looking forward to crushing
my first car since I haven't even driven
one yet all right looks good
that's nice car first up Adam clues in
Canon on a key myth-busting skill
shouting I need you to call it out and
it's like this this is Zoey little car
crusher in three two one
and then what okay can you give me
anything let me hear it let me hear the
voice
this is Domino car crusher in three two
one
boink beautiful with the countdown
rehearsal down pat the setup is complete
every single contact has to be perfect
next one straighten it up there we go
the spacing and alignment is double okay
so oh we know that five six and seven
are working great definitely and then
triple checked this is a one in a
hundred shot and they have to get it
right first time excellent excellent
awesome I was really nervous that eight
and nine and maybe even ten would fall
over they had fallen before we were
ready that would have been really bad
okay we're in the zone we're ready to do
this all safeties are off
[Music]
I'm putting your hearing protection on
all right thank you you're welcome
you ready ready call it in sir car crush
test by Domino in 3 2 1
[Music]
don't anybody move
I found a tool
[Music]
oh my god that is crazy
that is joy you guys that was
unbelievable I know how well that worked
up until that recalcitrant last domino
he crushed the car
considering the sensitivity of the chain
reaction and despite the final Domino
requiring a hint of persuasion in
essence it worked with no chance to
reset and try again the team will have
to call it based on this test alone this
sum this feeling the calm after the
storm
it's an old familiar feeling for me and
it's particularly delightful to be able
to facilitate it for a new generation
dudes
look at what you have wrought
I'd say the last domino has a big crush
on this car so how do you guys want to
call this myth okay you guys remove so
many tiny tiny variables from every
single setup to get it right I'm gonna
say it's plausible what would it is all
right well done Mythbusters
[Music]
you